where they're still thousands and
thousands of these people all on the
floor
screaming crazy and his voice i can hear
booming
through a microphone he's now come out
they've lost their minds and he's going
the devil
is in this church today and he's trying
to leave now and we're going oh my god
oh my god they were going to kill us
andrew gold welcome to the show thanks
thanks for having me
how do you describe what you do for work
i am
so the quick way of describing it i
would say is like a
a much less famous and less talented
louis theroux uh for those who don't
know who louis theroux is or
louis thoreau in america uh i like to
document sort of weird and wonderful
people and subcultures quite strange
controversial people
nothing is too controversial
everything's on the table
and trying to get to know why people
think differently from
from what i do and from what we do
whether that's in video form
audio formal or writing didn't you
manage the page three girls for the sun
at one point
that is the best thing i've ever done
yes that was when i started out so i was
like
21 or 22. who got i got in trouble for
that recently didn't i
somebody was tweeting us oh yeah
somebody reviewed my podcast recently
they said i've really enjoyed the first
ten episodes then i heard he worked at
the sun
not for me and he just completely quit
and i thought how can you enjoy
you know hours of stuff and then he
found out i worked at a place he didn't
obviously he was from liverpool and
they've got a bit of a thing with the
sun
um yes it was my first job in journalism
um and i was working nights
and you know the stuff i was writing was
just so tedious and it was all like
rihanna poses without makeup and i don't
even know who any of these people
were i knew who rihanna was and my i was
responsible at the end of the night for
making sure
the page three girl who for those who
don't know that's the they don't do it
anymore it was a woman on page three of
the sun newspaper who had her breasts
out
um and i had to make sure the 3d version
of her went up on the ipad
every night which was which was
complicated because i had i was having
these calls at four or five in the
morning
with like uh customer support or whoever
it is uh somewhere in south asia
uh titty support and i was just going
like look
it's not working and i can't get home
the titties they aren't here
there are gonna be a lot of people
waking up in the morning who aren't
going to be getting their titties and
you could turn her around with
your finger you could sort of twist it
around so
[ __ ] weird man like that's the job
that as a 14 year old probably sounded
amazing
yeah and then as a 21 year old wanted
that made you want to self-harm
like that's how i imagine the trajectory
goes
the deer was like that yeah yeah it made
me want to well who may want to get far
away from there eventually
so what did you do next well when i was
there um
yeah i had a bit of a i had been
studying in france before that couple of
years i'd been getting really into
languages
um french of course um and i was just
thinking i've got a
i've got to get out of this dreary the
sun place
every night you know i was work you know
five in the morning whatever and
i just thought where's the place i can
go that's the furthest away from any of
this
um and i wanted to learn a language so i
thought oh i'll get something that's uh
uh similar to french you know so spanish
was quite close i thought so where can i
go and i looked up medellin
in colombia because it's known as the
city of eternal spring
so i thought it's like 25 degrees every
day
blue skies beautiful so yeah i went out
there i just got i got a
flight i couldn't afford it at the time
really i got the sun
to give me like an article to do to
write about
the flower festival in medellin and then
i got
an airline i got in touch with all the
airlines and i
just just on the off chance i thought i
wondered if this will work uh emailed
them all saying like look i'm doing this
flower festival and i can mention your
airline or whatever and one of them gave
me a free flight so i
got out there and i wrote the piece and
the son never published it as far as i
know
and then i just uh quit my job while i
was out there and just stayed out there
see you later on titties i'm not dealing
with you anymore
yeah well the titties out in medellin
were a whole different uh thing because
i think it's like
the plastic surgery capital of the world
you're kidding me
people flying out to colombia to be
robbed at gunpoint get some drugs and
come back with a huge pair of knockers
well the colombians listening to this or
people of colombian heritage will not
thank
us for saying this but yes it sounds
like a good time
to be fair it sounds like a lot of
people yeah i'm sorry a lot of people
loved it yeah i love it out there a
fairly fun place what about this
exorcist that you want to go and meet um
so i'd been in
um after a year in colombia i moved down
to argentina which was a little bit more
uh european
after a year in colombia it was just
like i need something a bit more like
home
they have a different dialect as well
and i wanted to get into that the
argentine
spanish it's cool it's like italian and
they do all the hand signals
um and yeah i was there for like a year
or two i started making a few
short documentaries about things like
ufo hunting and um
what else infidelity i got made fun of
by
viggo mortensen on the radio channel
because he's quite big over there he
speaks spanish
um i went on live tv as well because i
had to defend this infidelity
video i was making because they were
saying to me like why why are you
assuming there's more infidelity in
argentina
so i ended up on live tv because of this
viggo mortensen encounter i had in
argentina
um accusing argentine people
of sleeping around is there a lot of
swinger
yes in argentina or something yeah yeah
there were there were at the time um and
there were nights
thursday is known as like cheating night
it was just something i know nationally
is this like a national holiday or
something at least in buenos aires and
that's got sort of a big part of the
population i don't know much about
outside of there but they were
yeah i you know i wasn't judging i just
thought it was quite funny and quirky
you know you're looking for things to
make a documentary but i don't really
care
but i ended up on a radio channel and
there's a radio show there
um where people call up to have affairs
so they'll call up and say hello i want
to have an affair with my friend's mum
so they'll call the mum on the show and
i'll say like
the idea is the concept is you have to
say three normal things so they would
call like the friend's mom and say
three things how are you good yeah i
don't know why you're calling me
you know um what are you doing today you
ask three things and then you say
are you up for it or some spanish
equivalent and they have to say yes or
no
and then they hook up what's the success
rate of that
more than it should be but i i don't
know exactly but the ones i listen to
most of them are saying
yes including like friends moms and
stuff
interesting all right what about this
exorcist yeah right so i've been there
for a few years
um and i saw him just sort of on the tv
quite a lot on the radio
this guy and there was something about
his face he had like an arrogance about
him you know
he was telling everybody things like
right you know next week's
halloween so make sure you've got all
your carrots and your this and that's a
ward off vampires
stuff like that on quite mainstream tv
channels out there
and i found it really frustrating i'm an
atheist myself but even if you're not an
atheist you don't usually believe in
that kind of
nonsense and uh people just took him at
his word and
these you know professional presenters
out there on tv on the radio with him
going mm-hmm oh yeah tell us what else
we can do
padre emanuel can we he was nuts so
i got in touch with him and said you
know i'd like to sort of
uh follow you around for a few weeks not
in a creepy way
and he let me come and film him
i think even if you are religious it
might be even more insulting
like to have someone hijack faith
uh because i mean i don't i don't know
for certain but i imagine that the line
between
dousing yourself in like olive oil to
ward off werewolves or something and
creating crosses out of carrots
and the christian faith i imagine that
well there's probably a pretty big
difference i don't remember that from
religious education
in school so i think yeah that's
probably a bit of a piss take all right
so you go see him and then what's he
like
where is he he was he was in the
impoverished suburbs of buenos aires
it's really once you get out of the city
it's really
in some parts quite quite rough and uh
quite scary out there
um but he but also a lack of education a
lack of
anybody that would tell the people out
there that this guy was a fraud
um so he was out there he had thousands
and thousands and thousands of followers
people who just turn up at his church
and just like
start fainting and convulsing on the
floor so i went to talk to him
the first time and there were just
people around my feet like you know
frothing at the mouth and i was like oh
hello mate and he was like
he had all the time in the world for me
because he saw me as english and
potentially selling this to the bbc he
loved that
he was very pr um prepared you know
he had um he played the music from the
exorcist the tubular bells theme tune
that was in his masses um
he had posters of himself superimposed
on on like the exorcist from the movie
and other superhero movies
around the church so this was a guy who
who really liked the attention so he
loved that i was coming to interview him
he didn't at all expect that i might be
quite critical
and look into his relationship with the
women who had schizophrenia that he was
exercising so is that what was mostly
happening was it people with mental
health problems
that are seeking a supernatural solution
yeah yeah i i mean i think that's that's
all that was happening really because
unless you believe in the paranormal and
stuff um
it so happens that a lot of the myths
and things that have been created around
demons and exorcisms and all these kinds
of things
are very close to real mental health
disorders which is i mean that's how
that happened that's how the idea of
exorcism
came to be because over the centuries uh
before modern medicine and modern views
on mental health
people would be seen maybe shaking or
having intrusive thoughts whether it's
ocd or schizophrenia
and that kind of thing anorexia bulimia
as well if you don't
have absolutely imagine what an
epileptic fit must look like if you
don't know
what that is 100 exactly
and you know what else you're going to
say hundreds of years ago other than
well it must be god is not happy there's
a demon what can we do
so he was actually
taking young women mostly they were
mostly young women
from a psychiatric ward nearby who was
suffering with schizophrenia and i went
and spoke to the doctors
there as part of this film for the bbc
and they said
it happens all the time it's not just
this guy there are people coming
they get in these people's heads and
once they're 18 or 19 a lot of them are
allowed to check themselves out
and they do so and they go to the
exorcist to be cured
the amazing thing is they they do get
better
generally but it's a temporary fix but
it's it's such a jolt of
energy and exorcism it's just it's the
most remarkable thing i've ever seen
and witnessed so yeah that's that's the
complicated thing about exorcism
what's it like being in the room while
someone's doing that
scary as hell yeah can you swear on this
i'm just gonna say
square away scary as [ __ ] um
it was really scary and problematic in
some ways as well uh because
i had you know obviously grown up
watching louis theroux and i wanted to
do this sort of
you know sideways glance at it and it
might i thought this would be funny
um so i went in just with my director
david hayes
who's a good friend of mine since we
were young and we just thought we wanted
to make this film together
and we we thought it was going to be
funny so i decided i would take part in
it
so the first exorcism uh the exorcist
handed me these bells
and he said these bells ward off the
devil so i'm standing
basically above this woman's head she's
lying on the floor before me
and i'm ringing these bells um hoping to
you know ward off the devil or whatever
and all i was thinking was wow this is
really
inappropriate actually this isn't funny
this is somebody with a horrible
mental health health a breakdown she's
having
um and that's when i thought right from
now on any exorcist
if we film another exorcism i'm not
partaking
in this yeah weird ritual
so what happens from there well like
roll the clock forward so you spend some
time with them you start speaking to
some of the
what are they patients like followers i
i struggled knowing what to say as well
yeah i say patience
i suppose but that implies there's some
medical thing going on
um yeah well we've we followed
um the first woman was a woman called
natalia who had some form of
schizophrenia i think
and then there was somebody called
candela who's 17 years old slitting her
wrists
she had bulimia anorexia a lot of stuff
that happens in adolescence
like that kind of peer pressure she had
and
nobody to tell her that's common you
know so she assumed it was exorcism
um after that they have to look at
themselves in some sort of holy mirror
and the fact that they're able to
actually look in the mirror according to
the exorcist
means that they're cured he always wins
i asked him do you ever not win
and he said now we always beat the devil
is it all right fair enough
and yeah i suppose i was sort of making
fun of him a bit still
um i was asking him more and more
outlandish ridiculous things like you
know so the vampire's coming here and
he's like oh yeah yeah we've seen a lot
of vampires
uh sort of pushing to see at what point
he might
snap you know i i enjoy doing that i
guess
as time went on we realized that his
assistant was this woman called paula
who um was in her 20s or so and she
had been exercised by him we didn't
realize this at first and it was his
most famous exorcism it's called the
exorcism of laura she changed her name
from
laura or laura to paula or pola
and she had stayed by her side since her
exorcism
and now i've tracked down her you know
doctor and everything she had also had
schizophrenia she had been
spent her teenage years uh living in a
psychiatric ward
and now was just with this exorcist guy
and we didn't know what was happening
with them exactly
um all i knew is that they seemed to go
upstairs which is where the padre or the
father
lived um and we got word from some of
the clergy working at the church that
they were a bit close and this and that
and something very strange happened
which was that there was another
journalist there at the church at the
same time as me but he was
very much a friend of the the priests
and he worked for the equivalent of the
sun
uh in argentina so he was a loving
republican titty parade as well was the
argentinean city parade
i think he might have been well at least
all the paranormal silly stuff uh
you know i there must be titty stuff
happening in that in that newspaper as
well
um but he he i think was jealous that i
was sort of you know
stomping on his territory um
and he for whatever reason told the
padre
that i had been asking why he kisses
this
young woman paola who he has exercised
on the lips
which was something that i had i had
thought might be happening i was
suspecting it but i never asked that
so i didn't know any of this and i was
getting ready to film this big mass or
whatever
at the church and suddenly the the
assistant powerless she said andrew can
you just come back here a second
so they take me back down this corridor
and
backstage you know at the mast meanwhile
there's tens of thousands of people
maybe
or several thousand people uh waiting
for the exorcist cut to come out they're
like
getting themselves into a further
they're really everyone's going crazy
the the the tubular bells exorcist
music's playing
i go backstage my my director david is
filming me
behind and then they cut him off and
they just say i just want to talk to
andrew
and david was sort of you know he didn't
speak great spanish and he's just trying
to say like well
hang on can't i and they go no no and
they sort of manhandle him out of the
way
they let's close the door um
and i'm scared at this point because
we're out in the middle of nowhere
nobody really knows we're even filming
there
this wasn't a typical thing where the
bbc would commission it um it's
impossible to get a commission so we
decided to film
first um just using like odd bits and
pieces equipment and stuff
and then sell later so nobody knew where
we were it was about midnight
and my legs just turned to jelly i
thought where am i here
and he's in the room with five or six of
his cronies sort of big
big heavy set guys some of them with one
guy in particular who had a big staff
like in aladdin jafar you know um
and he just comes up to me very like
he's obviously watched a lot of movies
and he goes he goes up to me and goes
like why have you been telling people
right about my relationship with paula
and i was just like i was like oh no
well i have asked about it a bit because
just because you're so close and isn't
that wonderful that you're so close now
after what happened and she had
you know and he was going mm-hmm and why
have you mentioned mouth kisses
and i was like i have not mentioned
mouth kisses and then someone
this journalist was in the room he's
going yes he did i didn't we can show
you the audio
we had this back and forth for about an
hour um
which obviously we had to condense to a
minute but he lost his rag
and we didn't even know i didn't think
about it because i was so scared i had
my microphone on my on my collar that
was still
uh recording and he was screaming and
going you
bastards you you took the falklands now
you're going to come and do this you
think you're walking in here
and i was just going no all right sorry
and he goes you say sorry sir i was like
i'm sorry sir and all this stuff it's
embarrassing really
anyway you know eventually we got out
there and that was not easy either we
had to sort of get away
we had to squeeze past thousands of
people who we thought at any moment if
he tells them to are just going to kill
us
um we would just be another statistic
out in the middle of nowhere you know
it would be nothing to them squeeze past
them
got out into the street where they're
still thousands and thousands of these
people
all on the floor screaming crazy and his
voice i can hear
booming through a microphone he's now
come out they've lost their minds
and he's going the devil is in this
church today
and he's trying to leave now and we're
going oh my god oh my god they were
going to kill us
and at that point we're like we're
running away we're trying to get to like
where are you even going to get a taxi
at like one in the morning now middle of
nowhere
and david says to me mate you're not
going to be happy here
um when you were leaving the church and
i was filming you
i wasn't filming it wasn't filming and i
was like right well we're just gonna go
then he's like
we we can't we can't not have you
leaving the church
so we had to then squeeze past these
thousands of people again
back into this like den and film me
walking out again which was the scariest
thing i've ever done
i've never forgiven david for that no i
love him really and yeah we got away
and we were so scared even on the way
home both of us just shaking
and it was only you know in the days
that followed that we thought
you know we recorded all of that like
this isn't just a normal film anymore
this is
you know it was all on my it was all on
my uh the microphone was on the whole
time
so that's what made the film we got
quite fortunate really
um so yeah it's what makes it different
i think the film the last 10 minutes are
pretty insane
so he held up a few thousand people's
exorcisms
to shouting you backstage while he's got
some snotty so it sounds like the
like the weak kid that befriends the
bullies in school it's like you did
yeah you did he was he was so much like
that yeah
how bizarre
that's why you do this job you know you
what you in the moment is scary
threatened by 5 000
argentinian people in the suburbs of
buenos aires this is why we're here
right
yeah that's what life is [ __ ] man
all right so how do you who the bbc
picked it up right
yeah how do you sell it to them how do
you say
i've got this guy who might be crossing
the boundaries of what a parishioner
should do
put it on your tv show what i had
mentioned to
a couple of commissioners and things
before doing it to see if they would
commission it you know
and they took a meeting with me and then
they just didn't quite take it
it's very hard to sell ideas outside of
the uk or america maybe at a push and
especially foreign language staff
which i think is a shame because when we
do have foreign language stuff on tv
documentaries and things stacy dooley
louis theroux whatever
they're talking through translators and
it's there's a lot that's lost there you
couldn't have that kind of argument we
had for example
um but they didn't want it so fine
um once it was done i yeah i got back in
touch with all those people saying like
no no you you've got to see this
me and david spent months editing it
putting it together
and like in you know all industries or
whatever you know they just didn't reply
um it took about two years of just going
on linkedin every day
finding the names of different bbc
channel four
like everyone and guessing their email
addresses
and just i probably said you know
there's the old thing isn't there about
like the beatles they got rejected
five times or whatever and harry potter
was rejected five times before
you know got and i just used to look at
those sort of quotes and things and
things i got rejected five times before
breakfast this morning you know
every day for two years an event and i
was looking at the vimeo
where we where we uploaded the video
just looking at the stats nobody ever
watched it like
one or two did the head of channel 4 did
at one point
at the time at the time and then just
said it was his he was worried that i
looked too much like louis theroux which
was a shame
yeah um but the bbc eventually
somebody somewhere and some team i don't
even know how
replied after two years and said oh
thanks for this i'll give it a watch
so me and david were like ah you know
two weeks just waiting like you know
fingers crossed please please please
watch it and we knew if he watches it
he'll take it and that's it wasn't
arrogance like we're such good
documentary makers
a big part of documentary making
particularly the gonzo style
with presenters and things is luck and
if something mad happens when you're
filming you've got it so it was just
luck and we knew
that nothing like this had been on tv
before that was this crazy just from
the luck of the draw from that crazy
journalist saying those weird
things that we'd done that we hadn't um
so yeah they they watched it and two
weeks later they said well take it
etc and they offered us an incredibly
low
amount of money which didn't even cover
the legal fees that we then had to pay
lawyers because they
they asked you to get all these lawyers
involved to check everything through
so we didn't make a penny from it they
took all the rights forever
because they knew we were desperate to
to take it
uh to get it on the bbc and it's it's
such a great calling card for us
that it was worth it um but yeah
we got it out and it was it ended up it
won some film festival awards first
and then it ended up in the bbc's best
of the year
uh list so it was a great uh moment for
us
have you been invited back to the bbc
since
uh in the in the sort of it was a funny
one yeah i thought that they would be
and i don't mean this arrogantly i just
i just thought they would think like oh
wow they've these two guys have just
done this on their own that's unusual
because usually would give a budget of
50 grand or 100 grand or whatever
and they've done it for free this this
is interesting let's see what they've
got
and no there was just nothing the film
came out and it was just like nothing at
all
i then pushed a bit and i was saying hey
can we have a meeting can we talk you
know
so i went to a bbc three meeting
with one guy who seemed to be sort of
the head of the team
and three younger women
and i felt very much like they just
i felt like they hated me from the from
the get-go they were just looking at me
with these eyes like who the hell are
you what was wrong with you
what do you think was wrong with you um
well at the time i wasn't sure but my
experience since has led me to believe a
big part of it is being a white man
being middle class as well looking and
sounding a
tiny bit like louis theroux as well uh
especially bbc three you know young
people it's supposed to be cool and edgy
and young looking and i wasn't
cool in that way they just hated me so i
was just coming up with idea after idea
like hey there's a
bunch of vigilantes that make
prostitutes stand on ant hills
in bolivia and uh there are these
pedophiles in germany where the
clinics don't report them to police i
had like 15 ideas like that just really
quirky bizarre stuff where i thought i
speak the languages of these places
um i can do this and everyone i said
they were like
okay well how would you do that i was
like well i'd go so
it was really a dampener after the
excitement that came before it i really
thought it would lead to more stuff
um and then i emailed they did say look
draw up a couple of pictures for us
for a series or whatever and get back to
us you know with it
in a week or whatever so a week later i
did that i put a lot of work into it
sent it to the guy
who was in charge of that team who was
the one who maybe had my corner
and he replied saying i've actually
moved to a different team one of these
women has been promoted
so i emailed her and yeah just nothing
no
interest at all some of the some of the
ideas i pitched not just to her to other
people they were saying like
why should you do that you're not from
that particular
background for example gay conversion
was one of them i wanted to do in
ecuador
um that it's a really interesting
thought i just quickly got it but
in ecuador uh they banned gay conversion
they they took the step to ban it
because it was such a
big thing and the the weird thing was it
got much worse because it got pushed
underground
um so then instead of just you know
priests and whatever doing it and
therapists
it became uh you know people would come
in the middle of the night and kidnap
someone and you wouldn't see them again
for five months they were forced
underground abused
so i thought that's a great idea and
they were like andrew can we ask are you
gay
i was like well i don't know no no
not a pedophile or a prostitute though
so
[Laughter]
as far as you know i'm neither of those
things no but
exactly that was my point as well so
that was bbc three and then
i had meetings endless endless meetings
for about
six years with production company after
production company
and every single one about halfway
through or three quarters of the way
through they would say wow these ideas
are really
exciting and we'd love to pitch them to
bbc and channel four
the only thing is we would just need
somebody from a minority ethnic
background to be the on-screen
presence and for you to be behind the
camera you don't mind that do you
and i was like well it is my story that
i spent years looking into and getting
all the contacts i would like to quite
you know be the journalist who
interviews them yeah yeah yeah we'll
just sort of
we'll do that but we'll have a presenter
from a minority on screen
i was like i'm not doing that to this
day i've never said yes to that because
it's just so
ridiculous but that's how it's gone why
wouldn't you
let someone from a minority group
present the idea instead of you
well whoever it is you know they could
have just said
thanks for the idea we're going to get
louis theroux to present it
and i would have said this is my story i
mean it's a big thing for journalists
and it's the same reason if it's a
written story
uh you wouldn't then want somebody
else's name to be at the top of it you
know
so yeah it was just that what do you
think
is the reason like what's the
justification behind this is there
a potential that you're not the right
man that you don't have the talents for
it and they
they're trying to palm it off in some
other sort of way or do you think that
there's an agenda
there's something more going on here um
you've got to be open to everything you
know
um and it's it's so hard to
self-judge isn't it so i wouldn't want
to say if i'm good or bad
uh it's it's hard isn't it it's hard to
know
uh well it's strange to hear it it's
strange for me to hear that
coming out from a meeting like
to hear that said sort of so
flagrantly feels a bit
icky to me um
whether you want no matter what your
sort of goals are
if i was a mixed race presenter i
wouldn't want to hear that the only
reason that i got this job doing this
interesting story was because of a
diversity quota
yeah well i've had people get in touch
because they've heard me talk about this
before
on my podcast uh and people have gotten
in touch saying you know i'm not even a
presenter and i was emailed saying like
you know i've heard about this thing
you're involved with do you want to
present
this for tv no way so yeah so it does it
does happen
um and and yes some people might think
as well well yeah maybe they just didn't
think you were good enough
and that's fair enough i mean it's it's
so subjective as well
um but but yeah it's just the thing the
thing was it was said
it wasn't even like 99 of meetings it
was every single meeting this was this
came up it was a dive
it was the same reason it was a
diversity thing
what do you think we should do about
this sort of situation
it's so complicated isn't it it's so
complicated the thing is
right now um on tv
uh in the last six years the diamond
diversity
survey that's like the closest that's
like the most accurate survey that
people use all the tv channels use it
that shows that people from minority
ethnic backgrounds are the most over
represented
group of people on screen in all british
tv over the last six years
and when you tell people that they say
okay but what about off screen and all
that and i said well that's not what
we're talking about though
so it does sometimes feel like these tv
channels are in a rush
sometimes to push diversity on the
screen
while not paying attention to what's
happening behind the screen so it's just
maybe a bit of a smoke screen almost
yeah
until although the thing is when you
look at the actual off-screen
stuff diverse the diversity we've got 13
of the uk is is supposedly from a
minority ethnic background
um 22 or 23 of on-screen
tv people are also from that so that's
it's almost double
off screen behind camera it's 12
or 12.3 percent so it's not a big
difference from that to 13
and you know it depends on on your
political ideology as to whether you
think that more needs to be done about
that
and i would say that the belief is that
higher up
it is a bit more white so the top
directors and the top ceos and stuff
like that
and as you say smoke it could be a smoke
screen because i often hear this from
the top
bbc guys who are like these white guys
and i'm thinking like well you're aware
if there is an
issue that's where the issue is it's you
guys it's not down at the
bottom as you know presenters on tv so
they could be perhaps protecting their
jobs by doing that but i mean what if
what would you say if it turns out that
the public respond better
to a minority background presenter if
they
are i think the same way as um asos
recently have been very at least on the
men's side have been very heavily using
mixed-race guys a lot of them have had
tattoos they've got piercings
all that they're looking at is how many
clothes does this model sell
of this particular garment they're able
to attribute success a lot more tightly
right because it's just click clicks and
conversions
but i imagine there must be something
similar there with the bbc
but it might be the case that putting
somebody from a minority background
who's the presenter
might result in higher viewing figures
or better retention or
better reported happiness after watching
the show or something
if that were the case then we wouldn't
need diversity officers and all this
kind of thing because it would suggest
well there's no racism in the uk
if the minority ethnic presenters
perform
so much better across the whole country
so they wouldn't need to be spending
extortionate amounts of money
on new diversity offices to up the
diversity
this feels more artificial than than
what is best or not best for the
for the show and then on top of that i
would just i would just think that
you know the people who discover the
stories as long as they're okay at it as
long as they're pretty you know you
don't have to be through you don't have
to be the most charismatic person ever
as long as you're pretty good at what
you do i think you should be able to
present that story no matter who you are
uh and it's i think i do find it sad
that we're looking so much at who
every single person is what they are if
you apply for a job at the bbc now you
don't just have to say
what skin color you are what this
ethnicity and stuff you now have to talk
about your parents jobs
you have to talk about your parents
university experiences
um your sex gender orientation all these
things where i'm like
i can't why are you asking you know i
also do get the other side
to an extent but it it it's uh it's
complicated
isn't it well it is especially after a
period where
certain groups might have felt
underrepresented if you haven't had
many gay presenters lesbian presenters
trans presenters on
there is a a justification
from the other side of the fence that
says well we've been under-represented
for a long time
it's it's now time for us to have our
time in front of the screen
it's i think it's what's really
interesting is
looking at how if you were to distribute
how much money gets paid across the
entire
bbc or itv the guys that are at the
absolute top you only need
five of them to probably cover an entire
couple of seasons worth of teams that
run
tv shows and i would love to see
the statistics around how many of these
groups of people that are being brought
in at the front end
are actually then working their way up
because that's very typical i remember
um
i grew up in newcastle with the geordie
shore phenomenon
and a lot of the show runners because we
would see them
uh twice a year they'd film every six
months essentially they'd come and do
about a month
and get a season out of it and do a
month and get a season out of it
so i would see this um sort of iterative
uh presentation of how tv works
so you'd see there would be just a like
crappy little runner
season one then season two maybe he's
like an assistant runner
or a researcher then he may be a
researcher then he may be an ap then he
may be a p then he may be an executive
then he may be a blah blah blah
and before i knew it i then went on to
love island and some of the people that
were runners on season one
of geordie shore had worked their way up
to being
some really sort of semi-important
person so it does feel like
there's a bit of a lineage that goes on
but also there may be a glass ceiling
that's been put in place
and if that's the case if the case is
that people are throwing diversity
quotas around
in a way to hide their own jobs
and keep their own jobs safe the ones at
the top of the tree
that feels a bit icky yeah well there's
definitely some of that
um and as to whether they sort of uh
my minorities now i mean there's no
denying that back in the 90s
80s uh there were these problems you
know
so that's also why there won't be as
many minorities at the top now because
it does as you say it takes 20 30
40 years to get to the very top um so
that is something
if that turns out to be the case which
would it would surprise me the way
things are going but
but then that's a problem and it's
something we'd have to look at why is
nobody letting
uh people from minorities you know get
to the top i didn't know you on geordie
shore before
love island no not on geordie shore i
was
one of the so i run events in newcastle
and
they filmed in a lot of our nightclubs
so we'd have
every saturday they'd come in y in all
over the place
and they used to pop it on in argentina
like i'd be in a bar and it had somehow
they'd have like geordie shore on and
i'd be telling all these artists is that
really what they're exporting british
culture is that the
best of what we have to offer is geordie
shore yeah i was loving it i was just
like
they loved it for some reason more than
like jersey shore they were loving
geordie shore so i was just
they couldn't understand a word of it of
course but they had like subtitles on
that in spanish so
god that must have been disgusting all
right so you didn't you look at an
abortion lady as well you go and do some
stuff with her
yeah so straight after um that film
because i was getting all these no's
about next stuff and i thought well
screw it i'm just going to go and make a
film
i'd been in contact with this woman that
was known out there as the crazy baby
lady
and she was just this really i'm really
drawn to very eccentric
uh bizarre types so i'm drawn to you
chris so
um yeah it was something i wanted to do
and she was just this woman who goes
around protesting
um people getting abortions right
and i'm quite pro-choice personally but
you're supposed to sort of keep that out
of the documentary
and i went and sort of lived with her
and this is the thing from doing this
kind of journalism i'm sure you found
the same thing talking to people from
all different kinds of
ideologies and backgrounds and things
you start to
often you quite like the people you're
with so i went in thinking like this is
going to be this horrible pro-life angry
conservative
religious catholic person who has
different views
about abortion and liberal things than i
have um
and i hung out with her we went on the
school run with her picked up her six
kids and she was very funny witty
and we got on like so well and it was so
nice
um but ended up arguing because again
she didn't like my line of questioning
and i pushed her a lot about
some things and she hates me now and
won't speak to me which is
really sad actually but uh but but what
it did was it it helped me as a
documentary maker to sort of realize
you know when when you go out to film
people who really believe that there's a
demon inside them
or really aggressively believe about you
know pro-life or pro-choice or whatever
then you come home
and people are just saying things like
can you believe people voted for trump
or can you believe
a brexit or whatever and i'm like well
of course i can i've literally just been
out with somebody who thinks the devil's
inside them i mean to believe
that's nowhere near as much of a push as
voting for brexit or trump or something
so that was just a really fantastic
experience for me to
to fully understand where the human mind
can take us
and how far it can go because i think it
can heal it
it can heal diseases if you believe
strongly enough in narratives we create
in our minds
that blows my mind that's incredible and
and it also makes me think there's no
point ever debating anything
because people's beliefs are so strong
yeah it's um there's a story from johan
hari's book lost connections
about depression and in that he talks
about this
guy who had a special
wooden wand thing like a big stick
wrapped in a special type of metal that
had
electricity running through this in the
1800s something like that
and he would promise people that he
could fix them that he could get rid of
their
like arthritis or something like
something like not just
mental stuff like physical problems as
well i think you'd wave it over them
and these people would stand up and it
turned out they stripped it back
so this they started doing um
a replica of that particular research
and
took away the electricity and then took
away the metal from outside of the stick
and then had untreated wood and then
took the stick and then got rid of the
stick
and the same effect just continued so
you're right like the placebo effect if
you could bottle it
it would be a panacea because it fixes
absolutely everything and
here's another cool story so i learned
that people that were catatonic during
world war
ii these um psych
ward patients right they hadn't moved
for years
perhaps some of them were just
completely out of it
when the bombs started landing and they
desperately needed people to drive the
ambulances
these men and women i think it was
mostly men
got up from catatonic states of years
years sometimes and went and drove
ambulances
picking up survivors and drove fire
trucks and stuff like that
so the change that you can have
when there's a sufficient external
stimulation
and the right type as well you know you
have a purpose you have a meaning now
this is something that and it can bypass
people that had been
totally like comatose for five years
that's belief and it's the most
extraordinary extraordinary thing
that's that's incredible that isn't it
darren brown sort of does a lot of that
stuff as well
um and shows why it's nothing to do with
religion it's all about belief and the
power of it
but it's also why we all disagree on
things so much and people always say
uh critical thinking you need to teach
critical thinking
but that's that there's a problem with
that which is that
even the smartest people in the world
who have amazing critical thinking
still totally disagree with one another
they're still led to different paths and
some people
really far astray and a good example is
is like
arthur conan doyle who wrote sherlock
holmes um
and i had david robson on my podcast the
other week who's a
journalist who talked who wrote the
intelligence trap about how the smartest
people in the world
often their beliefs lead them one way
and their intelligence sort of keeps
them further
they're able to um explain anything
because they're so smart
they can you know and arthur conandor
he's supposed to be sort of the master
of deduction and things like that
because that's what sherlock was he's
incredibly smart
and he believed in fairies um and and
obviously it was a different time but
nobody believed in fairies then
and he ended up falling out with houdini
the magician because
of his after conan doyle was friends
with houdini
yeah yeah until they fell out they fell
out over that
and because uh while having these sort
of arguments and things arthur conan
doyle said to houdini listen
you know your mom's just died i'm going
to take you to my wife who's going to
help do a seance
we're going to have a chat with your
wife now with your mom sorry
and so he was like oh okay right so
houdini turns up and they do this
seance and you know there's all this
stuff coming out about
christianity and this and that and
afterwards houdini said you know my mom
was jewish
and the whole thing was you know and
they fell out i didn't think
they didn't talk again after that but
you know he believed in these fairies
because there was a well-known
um uh a prank by these like
15 year old girls who just did these
cardboard cutouts of fairies and took a
photo of it
they're very clearly fake if you can see
them on google they're just
absolutely fake uh you can see like a
pin in the stomach that's supposed to
like hold it up on this wooden
background or whatever
um and he was just like well that's
clearly the umbilical cord so fairies
can have children
now this is the master of deduction and
this is somebody who's fantastic at
critical thinking
which is why yeah i just can't be
bothered to argue with anyone anymore
because
myself included our beliefs will take us
anywhere no matter how good we are
critical thinking
uh it's it's not going to help us agree
or even find truth or objective truth
so that's what the um abortion crazy
baby lady
taught me are you ever scared that
one day you're going to wake up and have
just absorbed one of these
mental views because arthur conan doyle
you think yep totally rational guy
totally normal
then one day just fancy's waking up to
believe in fairies like
tomorrow me and you could wake up and
have
like some in the exorcism thing you know
or whatever standing in ant hills
whatever it is that we've got to do
i i don't know i don't want i don't want
that to happen
i think i think what i'd be more worried
about is that and what is more likely
is that you and i already have those
beliefs and that certain people
listening probably not to your on my
podcast but
you know we'll think that i i don't
think we'd wake up and suddenly have a
different view
but our views you're right they do
change don't they and i think that's a
good thing
i think totally different stuff to what
i thought when i was 18. i think you do
as well i look through your reviews and
your on your
podcast and they're very different from
the beginning towards the more modern
what recent ones where some people like
he's changed
the people he's had on and it's like
well you should change you should
develop
my business partner recreationally
goes through the one star reviews and
apple podcasts just for fun
because he likes to go through he likes
to go through and see
people [ __ ] talking me because he's a
bastard here's another thing man you
know like people's
a lot of people especially on the right
they like to criticize the term lived
experience
because what what most people what
they propose people that use the words
lived experience mean
is unfalsifiable evidence that only
exists inside of my head
yeah but a lot of these beliefs
i don't think that the people that were
getting exercise
don't believe what happened to them i
think that the padre perhaps
was complicit and he is aware that he's
probably
not doing what he says that he's doing
but
the people that were working with him
they believed it and the people that
were being
conned they believed it and the people
that were paying and donating money
they would have believed it as well you
know ten thousand people in the street
don't come out
for something that they don't believe in
you know they weren't all there filming
a gonzo style documentary
subtly and it
kind of makes me think well the limit of
using the term
lived experience is actually quite
idiosyncratic isn't it everyone's life
is so different and so peculiar
and it does make it very i mean it's a
[ __ ] miracle that anyone's able to
speak to anyone and have a civil
conversation
ever i think lived experience as well i
agree with you and it's it's
loaded as well there's there's a it's
not only that sort of
uh i've experienced it so i'm right i
win the argument i've had lived
experience and you can't say anything
it's also if you do dare to say
something i'm going to get very
emotional because an emotional thing
happened to me
it's like the same with a lot of the pc
and the woke stuff
a lot of it comes from really good
places and if you've got a
friend or you meet someone you're at
lunch with them and they tell you about
a traumatic thing that happened to them
and they went to an exorcist
well it's probably polite to just let
them think
especially if it's helping them you know
but there are times
when we as a society it's not enough to
accept
lived experience we've all got lived
experience and all of our lived
experience is so
different from one another if you go to
a therapist uh
couples therapy and things like that i
know a lot about that as well because in
argentina where i was living i was there
six years
it's the world capital of therapy
everyone and their dog has a therapist
not really dogs
so uh every single person you can get is
like 10 quid to go or whatever
but therapists one of the first things
they'll tell like a couple
is uh look you've got your lived
experience but you've got yours as well
and there's the truth in between so so
they will tell you the lit experience is
not the truth it's someone someone's
subjective experience
and you should respect it it's good to
respect that and go like hey that's your
religion
it doesn't mean that's science it
doesn't mean that's true and again when
you've had your job
which is interviewing all sorts of weird
and wonderful people
how would you possibly know what's true
from everyone's lived experiences
so they're all different what about you
you spoke to a guy that went undercover
in an amazon warehouse what's it like
working for amazon
horrific horrific yeah that's james
bloodworth who's uh
a fairly uh lefty journalist
which which i was happy to have on
because i had quite a lot of righty
or you know uh james lindsey's and those
kinds of
uh helen blackrows and sometimes you
want to sort of redress the balance a
bit
um and he although he's quite anti-woke
i should say
uh despite being very left and for him
it was about the workers that's what
being left-wing was about about labor
actual labor
um and yeah he was there through
six months and it was horrible he said
he walked enough that his feet were
bleeding by the end
he you know he worked out that within a
week he could have walked from like
manchester to france or something the
amount they have to walk
because they can't take toilet breaks um
and the place is so big because they
have to cover a certain amount of ground
every day
uh if they don't if they don't do things
quick enough or fast enough they get
points and once you get five points
you're fired that's it no questions
asked
you get points for like yeah being in
the toilet for spending more than 10
minutes having lunch
you get a point for you know answering
back to someone in the uk
yeah he was at um i can't remember the
name of it was
he went to sort of this really
industrial town somewhere in the
midlands
um where basically you know there was
not much going on and the amazon
50 percent of the people are employed by
amazon yeah i think that's the kind of
place and it was just miserable
a lot of polish and romanian immigrants
and stuff
maybe half of them and then half sort of
english working class people
that he was working with and they just
lived in squalor the amount they were
being paid
and what really sort of boiled my blood
hearing about that
it was that it's one thing to say if you
if some people get
of you know very capitalist minded i am
myself and
it's one thing to say look well that's
the job that you're you know skilled for
and that's what you
took and you knew the conditions when
you went in there the problem is that
from from james bloodworth's experience
um they don't pay they don't pay on time
and they don't pay what they're supposed
to pay and what was agreed
so he said he found himself time and
time again just spending
hours knocking on the doors of his
managers going i was supposed to get 120
quid this week you've given me 17.
how and he said like the point is when
you're living in
in poverty like that that's the
difference between being able to eat and
pay your bills and being homeless
and it's not on and and so that it did
make me angry it did change how i
thought about amazon
and the irony unfortunately was that you
know i ended that i ended the podcast
saying like and if you want this book uh
you can find it on amazon.com
uk what can you do it's the problem of
becoming too big to fail isn't it
like that and i suppose i mean why do
you think it is
that the uk a place that has fairly
robust legal system
and employment law how come
this is being permitted so why isn't
should you only take one
case and then you could roll that out
across the entire country
it's just not on people's uh priority
list
at the moment and i guess you know that
the tories aren't that interested
in um stopping amazon from getting away
with what they get away with
i don't know if there are backhanded you
know bits of money going
to people into people's pockets i have
no idea and on the left
they used to be much more bothered by
that stuff uh but recently it's
particularly in the corbin era they
weren't talking about
working class lives really they were
talking about quite popular
uh university politics you know
it definitely did seem like that that
the original
liberal sort of slant on politics was
all to do with class right it was all to
do with
differences in wealth inequality between
the classes in order to
facilitate the labor to move up and uh
yeah i mean it's been a very long time
since you've heard it's mad to think
that you hear
conservatives talking about that those
sort of rhetorics now
more than you hear that from labor yeah
more but i think
i don't know what the stats are but a
lot of working-class people voted tori
recently didn't didn't they they've
moved over yeah i mean ashington which
is not far from me in newcastle
that changed and then hartley pool which
was this sort of
bastion that labor had had for ages yeah
it's an interesting one i don't know man
i
i feel like with amazon there has to be
something complicit going on behind the
scenes in
with regards to the government because
i've seen the is it we are not robots
amazon
union so they always have you know the
little robot it's like a cardboard box
made out to be a robot it's one of
amazon's masters
and they've repurposed that and i've
seen these picket lines or
whatever workers unions and then i saw a
video the other day
talking about it was a training for
amazon managers
for how to spot potential unionizing
behavior
so if you see your employees using these
sort of terms
if you hear them talking about this if
you notice groups of people that weren't
previously friends it's
super super scary and authoritarian yeah
terrifying
and um have you seen no mad land the
movie no that was what won
a ton of oscars this year wasn't it what
was that about yeah
that's it was about um i've got a name
francis mcdormand's
being quite depressing and walking
around the states but she
um was on the poverty line and she was
working at amazon for a bit
and uh it just looked fine it just
looked totally fine it was like i'm at
amazon i'll just pop in and have a job
and yeah yeah here you are chatting to
people and just
you know that's a big hollywood
production that's supposed to be very
real and gritty
and they really they really sort of
amazon doesn't come away from it looking
badly
didn't take the opportunity to perhaps
show amazon in the light that it really
is
yeah well i mean they probably got paid
well how much
employment investment you know business
rates tax rates all of that sort of
stuff
is amazon plugging through the uk i
imagine that
it must take a a lot of noise to
counteract
that much money to cause the government
to take notice
yeah yeah i i it's and and they're
they're based in
dublin i think is that i think i think i
might and that's hiding from tax in
dublin yeah
yeah as google does it as well um
it just seems like we squabble on
twitter about these little things like
you know jk rowling this and uh
like we were talking about before though
what's the perfect rate of
minorities to be on tv and meanwhile
there's just this insane stuff going on
and a lot of us again if you're a
capitalist you don't mind you go look i
have no problem with
rich people getting richer because
that's the system that we have it's not
the best system but it's
it's not the worst either however that's
that's fine as long as they're playing
by the rules rich people getting richer
fairly
yeah yeah precisely well i had uh janmi
park
the north korean refugee i had her on
the show recently
and um man she's talking about levels of
suffering
that hopefully the vast majority of
people on the planet are never even
going to be able to be aware of
it's one of those things it's so
harrowing and then she was saying that
the uyghur muslims in
china uh they were given what they were
told was
multivitamin shots which has now reduced
the fertility of that entire group by
half so the fertility's gone down by 50
like that's genocide
that's like legitimate genocide that's
happening within the last
two to three years and yet
we're being caught up like the smartest
minds on the planet are
either debating about genders or getting
people to click on ads
those are the only two things that they
do at the moment or maybe there's a
couple of accountants that are working
out how to get more businesses into
dublin i don't know but
yeah it's um well there was a time when
the smartest people believed in fairies
you know so
that's true as well yeah i don't know
do you think how much do you think of
the sort of current culture wars and
what we're seeing at the moment
how much of it is um genuinely generated
by the uk and the us and how much do you
think
is planted stories by bad actors from
nations like china and russia have you
thought about this
i thought about it a bit i mean i don't
know enough about it to really comment
except to say i read a great uh article
in the times the other day about
suffering and how much we need to suffer
and
i guess if you were born in korea you
can come away with a totally different
way of thinking of like
thank god i don't have that level of
suffering uh but
the best uh you know the best eras of
movies of creativity of art when humans
have created beautiful things a lot of
it comes from suffering
um if you look at aldous huxley's brave
new world the point is i mean we're
always looking
and and we do it in our podcast as well
we talk about we have people on to talk
about how to be happier right
well what does happy mean if you're if
you're really happy in brave new world
everyone's happy because they're taking
a drug that makes them happy
but there's no creativity there's no
literature there's no beauty in the
world
you need some suffering obviously not on
the levels of career
or something like that and i think the
smartest people
in the world that you refer to who are
currently you know uh
yeah talking about all these like
ridiculous things they're trying to
sanitize the world of
like get rid of any level of being
uncomfortable of being
bored of being a bit sad sometimes
obviously people have very serious
mental health conditions that have to be
taken seriously
but if we yeah for example but
sometimes it's like well you need to be
a bit sad for now
because you'll feel much better for it
later so
i don't know how much is i mean there
must be some level of bad actors
involved 100
i also think it's a natural human
impulse when everything is perf
you know not perfect when everything is
good compared to north korea compared to
the the entire the entirety of history
to look for
um problems to find like oh yes but you
should net why are you depressed why are
you bored
am i i i would have thought that i would
have agreed with that
if it hadn't been recovered if it hadn't
been for the last year
i would have said in the absence of a
real crisis we create our own and in the
presence of one we reset our values onto
what really matters
but then you have probably the most
globally traumatic thing to have
happened
ever to so many people there's never
been a single incident in all of human
history that's
affected as many people as the last 12
months as the last 16 months
um and yet
it seems to have further pushed us into
discussions about stuff that doesn't
matter i part of me thinks with that
it's the information overload
that there's so many sources of
information at the moment that working
out
what is in good faith what's in bad
faith what do i dispense with what do i
need
to retain it's essentially impossible
because for the first time in all of
human history we have a surplus of
information
for all of our revolutionary history we
would have really looked for information
because that was
like information foragers we were
looking for little nuggets of
how can i build a better fire where's a
better cave what's a better plant to eat
what's a better
route to go home to avoid being eaten by
a lion whatever
and now that same impulse to try and get
more information still exists
and we do not have the filtering
mechanism to be able to get rid of it
and the result has been
tons of stress a lot of difficulty and a
lot of suffering over the last year
people dying family members dying
restrictions on your livelihood
restrictions on the
the economy changes in your lifestyle
all that sort of lack of
social connection but that hasn't pushed
people
towards thinking about
a bigger picture about giving themselves
more perspective on what really matters
we got any sense about why that is
yeah i think it's it's a different kind
of tragedy it's a very specific
kind the last year and a half that you
know a lot of us know people who have
died and who've been gravely ill a lot
of us have been gravely or particularly
older people
uh but for the majority of us it's been
a very depressing and sad time but we've
been sitting at home
uh uncomfortableness
well yeah it's not the same as being
called up to the front line uh in world
war one or something uh by
any stretch of the imagination although
that that's not to negate the suffering
of people who have lost loved ones it's
horrific because that's that's
you know there's not much worse that can
happen than that but if you're being
called up
if all your loved ones are being called
up to the front line and you're sort of
sitting there god what are we going to
do
you're probably not going to be thinking
about critical race theory at that point
the point is
we're all sat here at home just thinking
thinking thinking
for like a year unless you did working
out or whatever on your own i don't do
that right so i like because i
i like team sports it's the only way i
can do exercise i hate
working out i get to you know i can't do
it i wish i could
um i couldn't play football for a year
and a half or so i'm sitting there with
energy
my girlfriend comes home because she was
able to work in a hotel which keeps
going during the pandemic
um which is a bit scary you know she's
coming home every day we're hearing
about this disease who she met today and
touched and been there or whatever um
and i'm sitting there just
stressed and what am i doing i'm reading
[ __ ] james lindsay
and critical race theory stuff like
everyone else in the world is
so i think it's a particular kind of
tragedy that's actually made us even
more
sort of insular and trying to find
little problems and little things
it is the most millennial way to suffer
isn't it that everyone's just had to
ingest youtube and twitter
and and netflix for a while
yeah i um you're right anybody that's
still here
that's still listening to this has had
that experience
they've gone through a year of this like
luxurious suffering
kind of i guess yeah yeah
really weird it's so bizarre what about
you infiltrated a group of pedophiles
that's been one of your more recent ones
what happened there
speaking of so bizarre yeah yeah well
you know i was looking for
controversial stuff and uh i got to
berlin
my girlfriend and i we wanted to move
back to europe she's argentine
and i've fancied going to europe and
learning another language german was my
fifth one i got all excited about that
and when i get to a new place the first
thing was like what can i do that's
really controversial and weird and
bizarre and try and sell that
you know somehow and it turned out that
berlin has the
uh the world's only sort of pedophile
clinic that doesn't
ever report them to authorities so they
can come in
a patient or whatever could come in and
speak to therapist and say i did these
terrible things yesterday
i'm worried i might do it again and they
will not be reported to anyone
and that's obviously very controversial
because it means letting these guys go
back onto the street to potentially
offend again
but the other flip side of it and the
reason it's actually pretty popular in
germany among
you know the locals is that it's seen as
the only way to guarantee these people
actually come out from the shadows
and actually attend therapy because they
know that no matter what they say
they're not gonna be reported and stuff
and they can get help
so the idea was like okay i'm gonna look
into that and either write a book
or a radio documentary or or a video one
so i filmed some stuff but i think it's
going to be too difficult because no one
wants to be on camera of course
um so i've written most of a book about
that and i've met
all sorts of you know the patience and
things um
recently a 25 year old woman for example
that fascinated me because female
pedophiles are so rare
and particularly ones who will talk to
camera so i took a train
out to the middle of nowhere in germany
uh some little village
and met this woman and she's got a 27
year old boyfriend
who is also a paedophile both of them
are non-offenders
they they both believe that it's and
everyone i've interviewed
has said to me they're a non-offender i
haven't i don't not very i'm not
interested in talking to someone who is
an offender
how much do you believe um 90
probably um this this woman i i believe
more because i i just maybe because
she's a young woman it just didn't it
just didn't fit the narrative
um and and she was so angry when she
spoke about other pedophiles who had
offended
um and so was her her boyfriend and they
the idea is that they both have that
view and they want to raise a family
together which is a scary thought
but what can you do i mean this is such
a minefield
wow yeah yeah look
one one percent of men
are thought to be exclusive pedophiles
now obviously one percent doesn't sound
very high
but in the world of 7 billion what's
that 700 million is it
in the uk in most countries it's
you you have you know more male
pedophiles than you have
people in the army you know it's it's a
lot of people
and those are exclusive pedophiles so it
gets scarier i mean the more i looked
into this and i apologize to any
listeners because
i've become a little bit desensitized
because i've been looking into this for
two years and i know
this is quite scary stuff to even think
about and talk about
but there have been some studies i've
looked at some surveys that have shown
up to 20
of men responded to saying they had some
attraction to
minors or maybe even it was to children
i need to need to check that
but they are not exclusive so most of
those people you don't have to worry
about them
they will never offend in their lives
they know it's wrong and they just don't
worry about it
that one percent they can't form a
physical attraction to
adults they just can't for whatever
reason
and that's scary because they might say
as you as you rightly point out how much
do you believe them
they might say like oh i would never do
that but we're thinking yeah but what if
you're drunk one day what if you're
feeling low
and this is saying they're not going to
cheat on their partner
exactly that's the issue and that is why
we have such an issue because everybody
asks me the first thing they say is like
how much do you trust them
and the reason we don't trust them is
because we don't trust ourselves and the
vast
the 99 of us thank our lucky stars we
don't have that attraction and would
like to think we wouldn't do that anyway
but i'm not speaking about myself in
particular but we cheat
at an alarming rate i don't know the
actual rates for cheating but everybody
knows somebody who cheated at some point
you know
most couples there's some bits and
pieces of cheating going on
so we don't trust ourselves so it's very
hard to trust
the pedophiles and that is a problem for
the non-offending community
and there is a big community of them um
and they want to say
you know we're not like those people we
would never do it but they can't say
that without us going
oh we don't quite believe you mate so
that's the
you know that's what they have to
navigate and that's that's the line i'm
navigating while talking to these people
it's such a challenging subject man i've
become really fascinated about the
ethics of it
i've had a bunch of conversations over
the last few years i remember there's
this girl i went to uni with
and um her friend gave a talk
and this must have been 2010 or
something so
like a while ago and um he gave this
talk basically saying
can you imagine um how terrible it would
be
if you were born with an affliction that
meant that you could only be attracted
to people that are too young to have sex
and uh it always stuck with me and i had
this conversation with a neuroscientist
guy called dr jack lewis
being on the beat on the bbc you should
speak to him he might get you on and um
he uh he wrote a book about the science
of sin
and they they put
uh people of varying sexual preferences
into fmris with arousal sensors
and they showed uh people that were
non-pedophiles every different type of
imagery that they could including
above and below the age of consent and
registered
what the response was mentally and in
terms of
arousal response and then they did the
same to the people
that had said that they were attracted
to children and the people that were
attracted to children they literally
couldn't elicit
any response from them by showing them
any type of
adult porn so the sentence that you said
that stuck with me
i i said look do we have any conscious
control over the things that we're
attracted to sexually
and his answer was no there is no
conscious control over that
and that that makes for a really
difficult ethical situation because you
think
well people didn't choose to be this way
and
only what 70 years ago
was alan turing was medically castrated
for being gay
because that was seen as something that
was unacceptable now there is a huge
line between being gay it's not only a
difference in degree is a difference in
kind
because you can't get consent and
there's a whole manner of of challenges
to overcome there but
if you are part of a community that
isn't
that isn't actually doing anything
physically wrong and you are
afflicted with a problem that you didn't
choose
at what what place is there in society
for these people
yeah i think you've hit the nail on the
head there and i think that's why i was
going to call this book
we need to talk about max max just this
guy called max was the first guy i met
from the
program in berlin and he wanted to meet
me
and he gave me an address i turned up i
didn't realize before going i cycled
down then it was a swimming pool public
swimming pool
uh which is a bit weird to meet a
pedophile there and
once i got in there to pay to go in and
everything is all a bit weird
he was with a little girl like an 11
year old girl and i said to him like
what's
what's going on here and he was like oh
i'm babysitting her for
these other people i know i was like but
you're a pedophile what are you talking
about
then two other girls came along and they
go oh hi max can i have some
money for the whatever and he goes i was
like who are that and he's like oh that
i'm also babysitting them
he's going to a public swimming pool
babysitting three girls who are his age
of attraction that's what he's into
so and he's trying to tell me about how
he doesn't offend never has done he's a
great guy he completed the course
uh why can't he babysit kids now that is
awful
and i've said i said that to him as well
but
the the point is i want to call them but
we need to talk about maths because it's
such a complicated issue as you say
i don't know nobody knows what the right
thing to do is the only thing we know is
we do need to start talking about it
because the amount of people
amount of children who are abused is
outrageous there's no actual statistics
because you don't know there's so much
goes unreported
but it's a huge amount of children the
only way to really stop that apart from
getting safer and safer schools and
vetting people
it will always go on the only way to
stop it is to stop
the pedophiles themselves now what does
that mean
well so you've got like different types
of pedophiles of course right so one
type is actually not a pedophile at all
at the clinic
you they get a lot of people with ocd
who turn up and say they have
pedophilia because they're obsessed and
they have intrusive thoughts and they
say i'm scared i'm going to touch my
children.
and they run tests on them to check and
they're like you're not appealing for me
and then they go home just become
obsessed with the
fear that they might be a pedophile yeah
that's really interesting yeah it's
called pocd
um for the pedophile ocd and it's a
really really common one and it makes
sense right
imagine if you've got ocd and the type
of ocd you have
because it's all different is intrusive
thoughts that's one of the most common
ones
now if you were going to have intrusive
thoughts things that like the worst
thing
possible pops into your head well that
would be it right
and it's equally spread out among men
and women with ocd
scared they're going to hurt their
children that kind of thing
but anyway that's one type of them but
of actual pedophiles you've got
you've got ones who are basically
crossovers with psychopaths and they're
going to do whatever they do you can't
stop them
you've got ones who will never offend no
matter what because they've got their
moral compass and they're aware critical
thinking all that stuff
in between there's this murky line of
people who are pedophiles again it's you
know it's a lot of people still
and who will with cognitive bias
convince themselves they're not hurting
the children
these are empaths empaths these are not
psychopaths these are people who are
good
people normally but they convince
themselves and we've talked about
beliefs
you can take your mind anywhere if it
suits you so if somebody somebody who's
born with those they will believe that
so if they turn up at berlin's clinic or
any clinic
they get taught over and over about what
it really does to a child and it
[ __ ] up their life it [ __ ] up so many
children's lives in fact
that's it you're basically killing
someone if you abuse a child
they need to learn this and there are
three the berlin clinic talks about
three um risk factors for these people
right they don't bother with the
psychopaths they don't need to bother
with the ones who are never going to
offend
these ones who might offend there are
three risk factors one is being drunk
they have to be careful about getting
drunk because obviously you know
it frees up their inhibitions uh the
other is being around children
you'd be amazed how many of the ones i
spoke to they told me oh i would never
offend but like i've just got a new job
as a teacher and i'm like what are you
doing why are you being a teacher this
is one of the risk factors you know that
and they've even told me i had one guy
on my podcast who was the head boy of
his school
18 years old episode six of my podcast
um i had to change his voice slightly
and he's sitting there telling me about
how awful it is to abuse you should
never touch a child
but uh he's like but i go to these after
school clubs and look after these kids
because i need to be near them
and i said what do you mean he said well
if i'm near them i know i won't abuse
them
and if i'm away from them it's harder
and i was like this is twisted logic
the third risk factor is stigmatization
and that is that thing where in a
community
if you say to someone enough you are
evil you are a monster
then they just sort of give up and they
go well okay i'm a monster then
if you say to someone instead and this
works for all types of criminals and
people in prison or whatever
if you say to them um actually
you're a valuable member of society we
love you we respect you we think you're
you know we think you're great and
you're struggling with something
difficult and we're going to help you
that person is going to do everything
they can to not
offend so basically we need to be able
to talk about it more that's the thing
i mean outside the therapy that i went
to see these pedophiles and to see this
uh
clinicians is graffitied hang the
pedophiles hang the pedos in german
and it's just like if they see that
that's not helping and more children
will be abused
i know right now that you you have a
huge following people listening
just by percentage and statistics
there's going to be a percentage of
people who
don't want to hear this who want to shut
their minds off and go oh god how can
you talk about such a thing
you must be defending it or whatever and
it's like what no we have to talk about
it because otherwise children will
continue
being abused and it could be any one of
our children we need to get these people
into therapy so that's all i know i
don't know
where their place is in society i don't
know what we do with them
because they definitely shouldn't be
touching kids and you know i
couldn't be clear about that but we do
need to talk about it without that
stigma and taboo of
you know otherwise nothing's going to
get done just like amazon it makes a lot
of sense
that if you stigmatize someone that
after a while
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
because if there's no
um salvation in normal life
if you're not going to be if there's no
place for you in this world then
fine i'll just retreat into my own and
this is where you get
dark net chat rooms and people doing all
manner of
of weird nasty [ __ ] yeah man i mean this
this whole area
is it's it's like the last taboo the the
final truest taboo
i think um there is no more
uncomfortable
conversation for people to have and i
understand
you know you see the uh
guys that i can't remember what it's
called it's like honey trapping but it's
for it's with
kids pedophile hunters yeah yeah the
american one that guy
uh there's a couple of famous ones on
facebook they always
turn up the people think that they're
going to go meet a young boy or a young
girl and it turns out to be this huge
burly
guy with a beard and some of his mates
looks like dog the bounty hunter
yeah and um you see that and you think
yeah quite rightly
these people they shouldn't be near kids
they should be off the streets
and then i mean you know your previous
readers some of them from the sun
um will be exactly the sort of ones that
either
hang them in the streets but if that
if that rhetoric if being so
using such a broad brush to paint an
entire group of people that has
subgroups within it some of whom deserve
compassion some of whom
require support and others of whom just
need locking up
if you use the lock them up across them
all and that then down the line causes
more children to be harmed
you're actually creating the problem
that you're trying to stop
yeah there's a certain there's a there's
a certain element um
and i'm careful when i say this because
i don't mean everyone but there is a
tiny element of
lady doth protest too much you know
there's uh similarly
with homophobia a lot of people who were
so homophobic turned out to be gay
you do find there have been certain
pedophile hunters who have turned out to
be pedophiles themselves obviously not
not the majority of them probably the
minority but that does
and can happen and also it's a case of
like well i'm so against this thing so i
couldn't possibly be one we're like
we've never said you were mate let's
just talk about it
or isn't it some high percentage of
killers returned to the crime scene
some huge percentage of arsonists as
well also returned to the crime scene so
i think that the police keep a log of
people that turn up
on the day that's one of the reasons
that they keep a log around the witness
around the police line they keep a log
of the people that have arrived because
a lot of the time or some of the time
you're going to find the person that
committed the crime that you're trying
to seek
there watching it yeah sort of
rubbernecking
and you know checking it out it's
there's this huge difference
particularly
the difference particularly in their
community the pedophile community which
has sort of delved into
you know speaking to them and stuff over
the last couple years and their their
their online message boards and stuff in
germany
and they get very offended and sensitive
about the difference between an
offending and a non-offending
pedophile do they have yeah well they
say that an offending one is a pedo
criminal
and a non-offending one is a paedophile
some of them are proud
uh this woman is 25 year old woman she
said this is my
gender or my sexual orientation i would
never ever act on it but i'm i'm this is
who i am and i want to be able to
express who i am
yeah it's it's so hard for us to get our
heads around
but one time i fell out with them all
because
when there was news about six months ago
or a year ago of madeleine mccann's
abductor
potentially being this german guy in
prison um
in germany there was this big news story
and i thought obviously as a journalist
i'm going to get the scoop on this i've
been in with these guys
so i messaged the message board i knew
about and i said listen does anyone
know the pedophile
being accused right now of taking
madeline mccann
um and they i left it for a couple days
went back and checked there were about a
hundred messages
they were livid absolutely livered with
me
and i thought what have i done what and
as a as a journalist you don't want to
lose your
you know you've worked so hard to get
access to these people and trust with
them
and i thought at first the problem might
have been that i asked them like because
these are non-offenders
and they're going why would we know him
you know why do you think we would know
a person like that i thought that would
be the problem
the problem it turned out was that i
referred to the potential abductor of
madeleine mccann as a pedophile
and they were saying he is not a people
he's a
criminal they were [ __ ] they were
like even the german newspapers like
build which is the german version of the
sun
even they wouldn't do what you just did
because germans are a bit more
sort of liberal and you know with with
pedophilia and stuff
and i was just like oh i'm really sorry
guys you know i ended up apologizing to
all these
pedophiles in the community but it's a
whole different world man that
and it's just so complex it's a really
difficult conversation to have i mean
it's not the first time that i've
brought it up on the show and i think
yeah every time every time that i think
about it it makes me
it's like such a cocktail of different
emotions
because there is disgust in there
there's a lot of ick
and you think why am i even why do i
even have to have this conversation
and then there's kind of a morbid
fascination with it
the the curiosity inside of me compels
me to want to
learn more about this and also to kind
of tread the
tight rope of acceptable and and
groundbreaking and i'm sort of pushing
new frontiers in terms of
ethics and things like that i mean i had
a conversation not long ago with a guy
called
sven naihom who is an ethics of robots
robotic ethics professor and he was
talking about the ethics of
child sex robots and if you take
continutism to its
end degree so if you talk about
utilitarianism is it
fair is it not is it is there something
sacred and representative
inside of the robot itself uh you know
even if you are able to reduce real
world
cases is it are you doing something that
is
unsacred by having this sort of uh
mascot almost of a child man there is
it's not endlessly difficult there was a
story of that there was a guy
uh i think he was venezuelan who um he
fancied this porn star or whatever and
he got one of these dvds from
um from like the street somewhere in
venice and karaka so i don't know where
and he was flying
somewhere i don't know the ins and outs
where was it like maybe to puerto rico
i'm going to say
or vice versa and he got stopped at
customs and they said what is this you
know one of these
little dvds and it's a woman who looks
very young
um and they they put him in prison and
they said this this person's clearly
very young
and at his trial hearing the
the porn star flew to the country
and turned up and said i was over 18 at
the time
so he got off and got some remuneration
for it of course and you know what a
horrible thing to have happened to him
however the reason that they that he was
in trouble is because
her body had failed i can't remember
what the name of the test is right now
but there is a test that is done
to determine whether something is
probably child porn or not
and it's based on like measurements of
the body so her
computer algorithm yeah and her body was
was according to the algorithm that of a
child just because of you know nature
that happens sometimes so
on the one hand he got off rightly so
because she was over 18 and able to give
her consent
uh but what does that really mean
because what he was doing was
being attracted to a a woman who looks
like a child and that goes back to your
point
is that then okay the argument tends to
be around that because it is illegal in
most countries
even to have like anime and cartoon pawn
of children
um so the argument around that is some
people on one side you've got people
saying it's good because it stops them
actually offending real children
and others say it's used as a stepping
stone like people say about that
or whatever yeah exactly so and there's
no consensus
on on that at the moment [ __ ] man
yeah i mean what's the essence of what
you're trying to get out here
just because somebody is over 16 in the
uk
or over 18 on a video
but looks significantly younger than
that
where are you drawing the line here
because if the outcome that the person
is getting from this particular piece of
work
is illegal but somehow you've managed to
create a situation in which the
particulars of it are legal
yeah [ __ ] man i mean good luck good luck
finishing the book dude because
that's that's a real
you've got to be a trooper of a
journalist to be able to go through that
i suppose have you found it
uncomfortable
to you know like how much has it
affected you personally learning about
this sort of stuff
the first time when i went to meet max
um that was difficult
and i uh maybe in an
old-fashioned man way i i don't cry i
don't
you know i mean and that's just how you
brought up right i cry at silly movies
maybe but i don't cry in real life
and um i met him and i hung around with
him i suppose for
an hour half an hour just my head was
swimming
because you're just like i can't believe
he's turned up with
three little girls when he's talking to
a journalist like what does he do when
i'm not here
what does he do i was just like abs and
i'm sat there in a swimming pool
place not in the pool of course but with
loads of people around me loads of
children around me who have no idea who
this guy is he's sort of this chubby
looking
you know normal looking guy wearing
little
speedos with a t-shirt over it and it
was just you know a bit a bit cliche
and after speaking to him i went across
to the park
across the road and i got an ice cream
just because it was about 40 degrees and
i was like i'm just going to get an ice
cream
and i went and sat on a little log and i
just broke down
and i don't i don't do that it's just
not me i get emotional of course
i do it's very did you know that feeling
when it suddenly happens you've lose
control of like you're shaking
and i was just crying and shaking people
were looking at me going past
because it was so real it was so real
and i i think you know after that you do
become a little bit desensitized because
you're working on it for so long
um and that is what i was talking about
you know when i said before that
you know i got to perform an exorcism i
got to do these things
that's i suppose my adrenaline junkie
for a journalist
a lot of the time that's your adrenaline
that's your fuel that was too much
that particular day but a lot of the
situations i get myself into when i'm
walking around a park with a 25 year old
girl
telling me she's a paedophile she's
actually attracted to babies
and i'm i am thinking like oh my god oh
god but i'm also thinking
like wow this is so weird and bizarre
right now so
yeah it's a bit of it's a bit of
everything it's an interesting one
because
you have to manage your own emotions but
there's another layer on top
that maybe people need to know about
this
and perhaps to get other people to find
out about it i need to go deeper into
the rabbit hole and
yeah it's strange man i mean it seems to
me that the world
the investigative journalist
there aren't those celebrities
of of that industry anymore
you know you don't have or i don't know
many of them i mean
yeah who was the guy that um that used
to work for the guardian
that did the stuff with not edward
snowden with julian assange
[Music]
young guy anyway i had him on the show i
can't remember his name i've got his
name god that happens you do so many
shows in the end
350 yen you you end up forgetting him
anyway so he he won a
pulitzer prize for one of his uh
journalism pieces and he
introduced julian assange or maybe
edward snowden to wembley
arena on by video feed so he came out
and james ball that's it james
um so he came out and did this thing but
it really doesn't feel like
sort of the investigative journalist
world has any superstars am i wrong
there or is that kind of the way that it
is at the moment
well there are so many as well now i
mean it's it's easier to be a journalist
in terms of like traveling getting
around the place in the 80s and 90s if
especially for example travel journalism
you could just get sent somewhere you
get given like three or four thousand
pounds to write a little travel piece
everything's paid for you it's all
beautiful and wonderful
now i'm competing as a journalist and
i've got you know the
the nctj is the journalism qualification
you need to work together
all of that stuff but you're competing
with like a billion bloggers you're
competing over a billion people on
medium and all this stuff and the stuff
that sells the stuff that gets views on
youtube
generally i'm speaking because i think
you're an exception to this rule because
you have some controversial stuff
and it it does well but we're encouraged
to have very lame
uh dull stuff because advertisers accept
it more
yeah safe stuff and it's bland and
that's part of what i was saying before
against moving towards this brave new
world where everyone's happy and safe
nobody wants to talk about taboo stuff
one of the reasons i wanted to write
about pedophilia was also because i
thought
right now i'm towards the beginning of
my journalism career and i'm not going
to be able to compete with john ronson
who's a huge star and there's a few
others like will store
uh and they go into the show in a couple
of
i'm getting him one as well yeah for his
new book yeah
yeah super good really really
interesting book i love that i'm excited
to get it
i haven't read it yet i've got it on pdf
um but he's pretty have you read his
books then
like before no no no this is the first
i've been introduced to him
oh he's great heretics was one of them
um and
again the stuff that you and i think are
very interested in and
you know the listeners will be as well
the beliefs and how people go and he
hangs out with these strange weird
people
and you just think i'm thinking like
well how am i going to compete with that
and i think the one thing they're not
probably not going to touch
is pedophilia john ronson doesn't need
that controversy right now what's the
point
he did psychopaths he's a huge star now
he doesn't need to do that so
you have to take that risk that kind of
risk when you're hungrier does louis
theroux have to go and
really do taboo stuff right now he's got
everything he needs he can get stuff
produced very easily in the 90s he was
really
you know hanging out with nazis and
stuff now he's sort of doing people with
autism and things like that it's a lot
still very interesting yeah yeah it it
is but
does he need that anymore so it's when
you're young and hungry i suppose and
you know yeah i want to get that book
out but it's going to be it's going to
be very hard to find a pub
if any publishers listening who's brave
enough to to be interested
you know get in touch i had
hamilton morrison you know the
pharmacopoeia guy from vice yeah
drugs that's right i had him on and i
think he did very much the same thing i
mean his first piece
that really broke him was flying out to
south america somewhere and getting
burned with the frog venom
and uh he uh he took ritalin i think did
you take ritalin that day i think he
took ritalin one other day
and he kind of made a name for himself
by mixing drugs even though he
understands the pharmacology of it down
to some
he he was blowing off all the people on
the internet that were giving him [ __ ]
saying they don't understand that the
androgen receptor for this particular
thing doesn't even bind to the same
the same receptor that the whatever drug
does and um
yeah i think he did the same as well man
so i think
if this is what it takes to to sort of
make a name for yourself
ethically doing something that doesn't
involve compromising journalistic
integrity but does talk about pushing
the envelope of what people get exposed
to
i think that's a way to do it but man
andrew gold ladies and gentlemen people
want to check out your podcast and other
stuff that you do where should they go
uh on the edge with andrew gold it's
it's on youtube it doesn't have much of
a following for some reason i think i've
got more of a face for radio
uh but on audio spotify uh apples cars
all those places um that's where it's
much more popular these days but
check out both if you if you want
i'll send them there links in the show
notes below andrew thanks for today
thank you thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace